Matt Ridley examines the link between
DNA and human behavior in his new book
nature via nurture he argues that recent
DNA findings have revitalized the nature
vs. nurture debate and the genes can be
affected by environmental factors
he spoke recently in Seattle for a
little under an hour tonight we're here
to welcome Matt Ridley scientists
journalist best-selling author and
chairman of the hilariously named
International Center for Life in
Newcastle England easier talked about
his new book nature via nurture now the
questions about what makes us who we are
have plagued us as humans since the
beginning of thought inspiring
continuous controversy among scientists
teachers philosophers and everyone who
is or has ever been a parent it has
inspired countless theories and even
whole bodies of psychological study yet
we have become no closer to the answer
as we gather information over the
centuries however with the excitement
around our new ability to map the human
genome we thought we would finally be
able to answer this conundrum but of
course all is not so simple
how silly and how human of us to think
it would be as he worked us through the
new mapping of the human in his
best-selling book genome so Matt Ridley
walks us straight into the middle of the
debate about what it means and doesn't
mean in his new book nature via nurture
genes experience and what makes us human
though the controversy and the hard
science are brilliantly included in this
book what makes nature via nurture the
indispensable science read of the year
and it is is the fact that Matt Ridley
has written it for a while I'm I am
making a strong attempt at reading some
of the other science books that are out
right now about this topic I really just
plan on reading nature via nurture and
calling it a day for Matt Ridley is a
storyteller and for those of us that are
humanities majors that still need to
understand what's going on in the world
in the world of sciences but also still
need characters and boy does this area
of science have a lot of real
characters they also need a plot in a
good story well Matt Ridley in all of
his books gives you that in spades
so please welcome Matt Ridley
Kim thank you very much indeed can I can
i bottle that and put it on the cover of
the book cuz that was tremendous
endorsement I fear I can't live up to
that after after that introduction but I
mean I'm here because I'm a writer I'm
not a scientist and I'm well aware of
that I there are many people who know a
lot more about the genome and what's
going on inside human genetics than I
than I do I just write stories and I
sell them to the public
I mean I'm part of the entertainment
industry if you like but if you were
gonna choose a topic to write about it
seems to me that to get a ringside seat
at the time when the first species in
four billion years on this planet gets a
chance to read its own recipe it seems
to me as good as stories you could you
could possibly cover I had a good chance
with genome to get close to that and I
realized that that we were just
scratching the surface that there were
going to be some immensely important
things coming out and then along comes
the publication of the genome in febrile
12 2001 the first time that the rough
draft was was actually published in
print and the headlines that made the
news was that it was a tremendous
disappointment there were only 30,000
human genes we were expecting a hundred
thousand up until a year or two before
the number had been falling and suddenly
there's only 30,000 human genes as you
will remember this was a moment of
national human well global humiliation
and people were seen weeping openly in
the street and in fact it got worse
because we've since discovered that not
only do nematode worms have 19,000 genes
but rice plants have 40,000 so but the
point was that this broke around the
world with a health series of stories in
the newspapers that week about how this
number was smaller than we expected and
therefore human nature couldn't be
explained by genes this idea of trying
to posit a gene for every aspect of our
behavior must be wrong and therefore we
must be the products of nurture and
therefore we have free will after all
which is a relief that was kind of the
way the story ran and I thought
something doesn't quite work here for
this for me in this there's something
wrong with this picture because we're
trying to break this genome on the
procrustean bed of the nature-nurture
debate and we know it isn't like that we
know nature and nurture work together
every but you know every parent knows
that it's a sort of complex combination
of the two and yet we don't seem to have
got any more sophisticated in the way we
discuss it so I hacked my way into the
genome and literally you can now you you
know you look it on me look it up on the
web and you hack your way in with an
attempt to try and come back with some
stories that would shed light on the
very issues that people in the
nature-nurture debate had been
discussing the you know things like
conditioning you know Pavlovian
conditioning and things like that you
know are there genes that now shed light
on how that works
learning in the general sense of
learning and all these different aspects
of behavior and so what would have come
back with is some I think a fresh take
on on the nature-nurture controversy but
I also have tried to tell the history of
that debate as well it's fresh not
because its conclusion is anything that
radical I mean I think we all realize
that its nature plus nurture or nature
with nurture or as I've called it nature
via nurture in order to distinguish from
nature versus nurture
but it's pressed because I think
actually that's suddenly a much more
interesting argument than we thought
because we can actually see the genes at
work and the bottom line if you like is
that genes are the mechanisms of
experience genes are at the mercy of our
behavior genes are actually changing the
way they act minute by minute inside our
brains and that's what makes them
completely different from these sort of
Oracle's of Delfy that people have have
tried to think of them as up until now I
should just say that I think one of the
one of the really interesting other
themes that I've tried to follow is is
the question of how we're different from
other species
what what is that better could you not
hear me you know what what is it about
humans that makes them human as opposed
to chimpanzees and it's very exciting to
be here in Seattle because I know
maryclaire King is here and she was the
person who first discovered that you
could measure the similarity between
human beings and chimpanzees by looking
at their DNA back in the 70s and she
came back with the conclusion that to
all intents and purposes there was no
difference we now know it's it's less
than 5% difference in the genome and
that chimpanzees are more closely
related to us than they are to gorillas
and other moments of humiliation for our
species were not special after all but
it's got it got worse with the
publication of the genome because we
discovered that the 30,000 genes is not
just a smaller number than we expected
we had after all expected I mean people
were talking about literally half of the
hundred thousand genes we expected would
be used to build the human brain and
would be peculiar to human beings with
turns out it isn't like that because the
30,000 genes are not only the same
number as you find in a chimpanzee or a
mouse but they're basically the same
genes it's the same set of genes so how
come if it's the same set of genes we
don't look like chimpanzees or mice the
answer I'm sure lies in the control
regions of the genome that's the little
stretches of DNA upstream of genes which
decide when a gene is switched on and
off and these control regions are
surprisingly sensitive to things that go
on in our environment and they're also
surprisingly variable between species so
that essentially what they're doing is
turning the thermostat up and down on
particular genes so that you're getting
the same you're getting a different
organism built out of the same
ingredients it's a bit like using a
different recipe with similar
ingredients and a beautiful example of
this came up just a year or two ago
which is there's a gene called Hawk c8
which is found in all mammals and it
specifies where the embryo starts to
build a thorax
when it's building the spinal cord from
front to back where it starts to say
this is the thorax this is the pit the
bit with the ribs as it were and hocks
c8 is exactly the same really
effectively the gene in a chicken and in
a mouse and or in a human being or
indeed a snake but it's switched on at a
different period and for a different
length of time so that in the chicken
it's switched on later so that you get
more neck and less thorax in the mouse
it's switched on earlier so you get less
neck and more thorax and in the Python
it's switched on right at the beginning
so you get one long thorax which is just
a beautiful little story and the
differences in line not in the gene but
in the control region upstream of the
gene so that's to me that's that that's
an exciting in a wholly new idea about
how evolution works in in mammals that
it works by changing these control
regions but we're not just slightly
different from chimpanzees there are
qualitatively differences between us and
one of those one of the most important
ones is language
now clearly animals can communicate with
each other but the sophistication and
the range and the syntax on the grammar
and the vocabulary of human of human
language is immensely more complicated
than the most sophisticated ape or-or-or
monkey and all the evidence suggests
that it's in some sense innate that
there's a there's a capacity and a human
child to acquire language that there is
not there in other animals and I think
one of the most exciting genes that I've
come across and that I write about in
this book is the gene that may let us
into this process that may give us an
inkling into what's going on in in human
language it's called fox p2 and it's on
chromosome 7 and it was found in a
pedigree of people a large kindred a
family of people who who had a problem
with language in other words about half
the members of this family simply have
trouble speaking have trouble learning
grammatical rule
have trouble generalizing ideas about
syntax and grammar they have normal IQs
but they that you know they they stumble
that over over languages and it's
entirely illegitimate to say that
President Bush has this this problem so
I didn't say that
the the the we became possible in this
family to look at the people who had
this problem and the people who didn't
have this problem and try and see what
the difference was between them even
though they're closely related and by
looking at the genetic marker that was
consistently different between them
it soon became apparent that the
difference lay in a gene on chromosome 7
called fox p2 and when broken this gene
seems to prevent you acquiring language
in the normal way hooray we found the
gene for language we can go home and say
this is the gene which if you've got it
you speak English
and if you haven't used to be well
French so suppose well hang on there's
the problem immediately language is
something that's acquired its nurture
not nature so what is this gene doing
well the first surprise is that if you
look in chimpanzees or indeed in mice
you find they've got fox b22 so it's
again as I say it's the same set of
genes somehow this gene went broken
prevents us learning language but it's
also found in Apes and and and and mice
however semantics barber in Leipzig did
an analysis of this gene which proved a
remarkable and interesting thing which
is that the gene is very highly
conserved it doesn't change very much in
evolution most mammals have virtually
identical versions of this gene and the
changes that do happen are ones that
don't matter that don't change the
protein fact they've been only two
changes in the whole mammal lineage so
far in the animals that have been looked
up but in the human line since the
common ancestor with a chimpanzee have
been two additional mutations - two
extra changes to this gene and if you
look at the area around these two
changes you find that they've been
subject to what's called a selective
sweep in other words that version of the
of the of the gene has elbowed aside all
the other versions in the ancestors of
every person alive today so that we're
all descended from people who had a
mutation to mutations in this gene and
the interesting thing is but but there
by looking at these silent mutations
nearby you can date this and you can say
that this happened very recently by
which I mean between 100,000 and 200,000
years ago now that's very exciting
because a it's the time when suddenly
something weird happened to the human
species we'd been bumbling along for a
million years making beautiful stone
tools the akule e'en hand axe fantastic
equipment but without changing the
design and then suddenly sometime
between 200,000 and a hundred thousand
years ago first of all in Africa and
then because people spread out of Africa
and replaced all the other people in
Eurasia
there's a huge change in sudden you get
something called well for Bennett for
want of a better word progress
cumulative culture you start to be able
to build on the ideas and that other
people have had in different places in
different parts of the world culture
kind of takes off around that time and a
lot of other evidence has suggested that
language really wasn't hunting along
very nicely until then either that
language came along comparatively late
in our evolution and probably around
that period so could this be the genetic
change that enabled us to to learn to
speak I mean it would be too good to be
true almost if it were because we've got
30,000 years to look at and one of the
first few hundred that we've looked at
seems to show this there will probably
be others but it may well be one of the
genes that enabled this transformation
in human beings to allow cultural
takeoff but it's a gene for nurture if
you like it's a gene for allowing you to
learn language
it's a genetic change that somehow
changed our wiring in the brain so that
you were you were capable of absorbing
language not so that you were capable of
speaking language because we know and we
know from
cruel unintentional experiments the
children deprived of contact with with
speaking people for the first 13 years
of their life can never acquire language
there's a critical period in youth when
you're very very good at absorbing
vocabularies and fitting them into
innate grammars in your head and if you
don't get that exposure you don't learn
to speak so it's quite a means very
interesting to imagine the first human
being who had this mutation and who aged
3 starts to expect to learn language and
who's he going to learn it from
obviously it would have had to be a very
gradual process that each generation
would have given each other a
cumulatively better language which would
have enabled them to be cumulatively
more cultural and more technological and
so on so something like that may lie
behind a very important transformation
in human nature around that time but
there's another difference between us
and chimpanzees which is that we pair
bond and shoot chimpanzees don't on the
whole in in most human societies we live
in we live we live in monogamous pair
bonds give or take a few exceptions
whereas chimpanzees are much more
promiscuous this difference is mirrored
in another pair of species the Montaigne
vowel and the Prairie vole which are
little rodents the montane vole is
promiscuous male meets female male mates
with female male disappears into the
sunset female is left to bring up the
babies typical rodent behavior if you
like in the Prairie vole male meets
female they mate and from there off from
there on they're inseparable and the
male helps to bring up the babies what's
the difference well could you really
trace that back to the genome surely
it's a behavioral difference that's
again a mixture of acquired and learnt
and traditional and all this kind of
thing well Tom Insel and Larry Young at
Emory University have done a whole
series of experiments which basically
pin down the oxytocin system and the
vasopressin system as being the causes
of this these are two little hormones
that are used in the body but they're
also used in the brain at various points
and they they in particular seem to
bring on affiliative behavior bonding
behavior between individuals they're
used for example for a sheep to bond
with its lamb oxytocin is released into
into the brain to help sheep bond with
the lamb and it turns out that if you in
if you raise a vowel that can't produce
oxytocin it won't pair bond until you in
prairie vollis's until you inject
oxytocin into its brain at the just the
right point at which point it will
effectively fall in love with the
nearest bowl so you can bring on pair
bonding just like Oberon brought on
what's he called titania falling in love
with bottom the Weaver with is with the
head of an ass by dropping a special
substance on her eyelids it's the same
concept Shakespeare as usual got there
first but we now know that you'd have to
actually cannulate to Tanya's medial
amygdala which is a major operation to
get the oxytocin in there but so what
why does this happen in the prairie well
if you inject the oxytocin into the
montane role it does nothing it doesn't
get pair-bonded and the reason is
because the receptor gene the receptors
but for the oxytocin are expressed in
different parts of the brain in the two
species they're expressed in the medial
amygdala in the Prairie vole and in a
different part of the brain in the in
the Montaigne vole and if you look at
the genes for those receptors you can
find why they're expressed in different
parts and it's because the control
region of the gene is different the bit
was not translated but tells the gene
when to switch on and when not to switch
on and so during the development of the
brain it gets switched on at a different
time and therefore appears in a
different part of the brain and the
difference lies is caused by an
insertion of text at a paragraph if you
like that's been plugged into the middle
of the control region of the prairie
voles gene so
that this paragraph causes a different
expression of the gene that paragraph is
highly variable in length between
individuals which is intriguing it imply
and it the reason it's variable is
because it contains a lot of repeats a
lot of these stutters where the the DNA
can lose its place when it's copying so
you get a variable length human beings
have a similar insertion with similar
repeats in this in the control region of
the same gene and it's highly variable
between individuals I won't say any more
than that but it's an intriguing thought
but again we're talking here about a
gene that this isn't a gene for falling
in love this is a gene for responding to
an experience it's a gene for giving you
the capacity to respond in one way or
another to a particular experience and
we're not all the same we've talked
about you know how human beings are
different from chimpanzees or prairie
voles from Montaigne voles but one human
being is different from another and can
we understand some of that again in
terms of genes for experience genes for
nurture if you like and there's a lovely
example of that that's just come out
last year in the monoamine oxidase a
gene in the on the X chromosome just can
Howe drink the young the monoamine
oxidase a gene is a notorious gene
because it was discovered in a Dutch
family in the 1980s to be broken in
certain members of those family of that
family and the people who had a broken
version of that gene were all in jail
and essentially the argument was that
this was the criminality mutation well
it turned out that it does indeed
explain whether you go to jail in that
Dutch family but it's confined to that
Dutch family that mutation has never
been found outside it so it doesn't
explain criminality and society at large
which is a nice example of how you have
to take with a pinch of salt discoveries
of genes related to behaviors like that
but there's a much commoner genetic
difference in that gene which is a
genetic difference in the control region
upstream of the gene the promoter and
the difference essentially is that the
control region is longer or shorter if
you've got the middle length the
intermediate length of this thing then
you have a more active version of the
gene the gene is switched on at a higher
volume if you like if you've got the
other kind then it's switched on at a
lower volume and about two-thirds of us
have the higher volume version and about
a third of us have the lower volume
version of this gene and because it's on
the X chromosome men have only one copy
of this gene women have two copies so we
have got a spare if one goes wrong or if
they don't like one they can use the
other so the only effect you're going to
pick up is gonna be more obvious in men
well let's just step back a second and
forget about the gene for a second and
and ask a simple question a very nurture
based question a very environmentalist
question if you like which is does child
abuse does maltreatment of children
cause them to be LT antisocial as adults
most social scientists think that there
is a link that and that it's not just a
correlational link but it is actually
causative but you might argue that
what's happening is that the reason
these children are antisocial is because
they've inherited the same personality
that caused their parents to be child
abusers so it could be a nature
explanation not a nurture explanation so
we get into the usual nature argument
which is it is it nature or is it
nurture well what Terry Moffitt and her
colleagues at University College London
did was do an interesting study in a in
a group of New Zealand boys who've been
studied for 30 years since their birth
every year and followed up in every
detail of their lives to to try and
answer this question and they found it
there was indeed a correlation between
becoming an antisocial adult and getting
into trouble with the law and having
been maltreated as a child but it
and a particularly strong correlation
until they broke the population down
into the two samples those who had the
high active version of the the monoamine
oxidase a gene and those who had the low
active version those who had the high
active version had virtually no
correlation so they're essentially
immune to maltreatment those who had the
lower active version were fine if they
were not maltreated they were not
antisocial as adults but they were
highly antisocial they did hugely more
than their share of crimes for example
as adults if they'd had both the lower
active version of the gene and the
childhood maltreatment so what's
happening here is that the the the
genetic difference is making some people
more vulnerable to a certain kind of
experience the gene is as it were
responding to the environment I just
want to end by talking about one
particular experiment that I really
loved which I came across when I was
writing this book it's not one that I
can identify a gene for it's one that
nonetheless I think illustrates
beautifully how nature to work together
rather than against each other any
concerns fear of snakes many people are
afraid of snakes it's in fact it's the
Communist human phobia and it makes no
sort of logical sense in the modern
world to be afraid of snakes you should
be afraid of cars instead but it does
actually of course make logical sense
back in the Stone Age to be afraid of
snakes so in that sense it looks like
maybe it's an instinct maybe it's
something that we inherited from our
ancestors who learnt the hard way by
natural selection are you by dying when
they were not afraid of snakes that
snakes are frightening it's an instinct
we share with other animals too monkeys
are on the whole afraid of snakes
but what Susan Monica at the University
of Wisconsin discovered was that while
monkeys that have been born in the wild
are indeed afraid of snakes monkeys that
are born in captivity have no fear of
snakes and the way she tested this was
by
putting a monkey in its cage a hungry
monkey and he had to reach for his
peanuts and there was a snake in the way
would it reach over the snake to get at
the peanut the wild born monkeys in the
back of the skate cage screaming the
captive born monkey they're down in
separate rooms you know so they can't
see each other of course the captive
born monkey reaches happily across the
snake to get the peanut she then
discovered that it was possible to do
the experiment to get exactly the same
result with a plastic snake so she
didn't have to control the movement of
the snake and she then thought of this
brilliant experiment what she would do
was show a video of the wild born monkey
reacting with fear to the snake to the
captive born monkey and see if it learnt
from the video first of all she tried it
with real monkeys and they learned from
each other so clearly the social
learning going on here and then she
tried it with the video and yeah even
with a pretty crummy video not a very
good picture of a snake on it the
captive born monkey quickly picks up but
snakes are scary and from then on it's
afraid of snakes
- so she next doctors the video so that
the bottom half of the screen where the
snake is visible in the picture is
replaced by an image of a flower and the
captured born monkey has never seen a
flower either so it should acquire a
fear of flowers from this picture it
doesn't it simply concludes that some
other monkeys are crazy
well no this is very interesting because
having at first thought this was an
instinct we then said well actually it's
learnt but now we're finding that the
learning is biased by sort of
preparedness by sort of predisposition
that you can learn to fear snakes much
more easily than you can learn to fear
flowers so actually its nature and
nurture there's that there's a nature
for learning snakes but it has to be
developed if you like in a fluid bath
called experience well where does all
this leave us in respect of the question
of determinism and freewill
have I just outlined a horrible
situation where either nature or nurture
is causing our behavior in whichever it
is it it means that we have no control
over our own destiny
philosophers have wrestled with the
question of freewill for many millennia
and they've said very interesting things
on the subject although on the whole I
don't feel myself that they've kind of
given me an answer that I find
satisfying Spinoza said that the only
difference between a human being going
through life and a stone rolling down
the hill is that the stone is under no
illusion that it has control of its own
destiny and David Hume said that either
our actions are determined in which case
there's nothing we can do about them or
our actions are random in which case
there's nothing we can do about them I
don't find either of those remarks
helpful because I do feel that I have
freewill that I do have control of my
own destiny where does it come from
if in some sense we are caused by our
experiences and by our genes it's a
paradox that I think our brains are not
very well equipped to find a way out of
and I suspect the answer lies partly in
the fact that causes in this case are
often circular that causes can become
their own effects and vice versa and
that we're not very good at handling
circular causality in our brains just as
we're not very good at handling things
like quantum mechanics in our brains but
I think there's also another very
interesting idea out there which it's
worth considering and it starts really
with William James
the American philosopher in the late
19th century who argued that human
beings have more instincts than animals
not fewer that we have a whole bunch of
instincts that a monkey doesn't have but
that that the more instincts we have the
less of an automaton we are you don't
have having more instincts doesn't give
you less freedom he didn't really expand
the point much beyond that but I think
Daniel Dennett has expanded the point
recently in his book freedom evolves
where he argues that the free freedom
free will is something that that is a
gradual thing it's not in all olden I
think you had you don't have it or not
have it and you win it by first of all
being a mobile animal so you can move
out the way certainly being an
intelligent animal so you can think
about issues thirdly being a conscious
animal so you can you know bill be
self-aware and fourthly by sort of doing
science and by knowing your destiny you
can make that destiny not inevitable but
evitable and one way of knowing your
destiny is to do science and understand
the genes involved so actually the more
we study this the more free we get and
that's my rather uplifting thought about
this and let me give you just a little
example of what I mean dyslexia is
something that we used to be rather
puzzled by but in recent decades we've
concluded that it's basically innate
that the reason some people are dyslexic
and other people are not is because they
there's something genetically different
about the people who are dyslexic
has that led us to throw these people on
the educational scrap heap and say
there's no function trying to teach them
to read of course it hasn't it's had
exactly the reverse effect it's
redoubled our attempts to find ways of
teaching dyslexics to read and very
successfully to and so by recognizing
that it was their fate to find reading
difficult we found a way around a
problem and we've given them as it were
the freedom to learn to read as well
so on that hopefully uplifting note that
that knowledge equals Evert ability and
therefore freedom
I will I've given you a taste of some of
the tales that I tell in the book and I
hope you enjoy reading the rest of them
and I'm very happy to answer any
questions
curious you should mention Dennett I'm
wondering what your opinion on Steven
Pinker's the blank slate and his
arguments there on how they confer with
yours what's my opinion on Steven Pinker
of a blank slate I actually think the
blank slate is a wonderful book I'm a
huge fan of it and not everybody is I
know but it does something rather
different from my book which is it tries
to demolish a particular argument that's
um that's been made that we are purely
the products of of experience it tries
to you know tries to say look stop being
so dogmatic about it there is clearly
something innate in us as well and and
if you take it on that level I think
it's a very fine argument Steve Pincus
book is much more about neuroscience and
much less as it were about genes than
mine is not really a geneticist but I
think I think also what I've tried to do
here that's a little different from
Steve is take the best from both sides
of this debate because actually Freud
had something to offer Skinner had
something to offer Darwin had something
to offer they're all right in a sense
about what they really knew about they
were horribly wrong about what they said
about each other often in this debate I
really noticed that you know that that
guy's on one side of the debate we're
saying how you know I believe in the
middle of the road it's that guy over
there it was an extremist and I do think
that in some sense maybe Steve has
fallen into that trap a little bit
although as I say I do think it's a
wonderfully written book so I don't want
to be rude about it because that would
just be doing the same thing yep yes are
you familiar with John Gray out of
School of Economics in London London
School of Economics and his book a straw
dog's throat dog I've looked at it I
can't say I've read it from from from
cover to cover that's John Gray's book
straw dogs are not different from
animals and therefore we don't believe
in and animals having pretty well why
should we believe that we humans have
free well yes I mean I think the the
argument from similarity and difference
is a fascinating argument actually even
Darwin was the the person who really
nailed this beautifully and the book I
begin my book with with Darwin landing
on terra del fuego and for the first
time meeting what he called savages and
being really appalled I mean here's a
Cambridge graduate who has just been
trained for the church and you know high
Victorian society and things and you
know they're here these people with
burns through then as is half-naked
dancing and he's you know it's the
genuinely shocking moment to him because
he's shocked that human beings can sink
so low as he puts it that they look like
animals and that's suddenly they look
like animals they're not unlike they're
so unlike me that maybe they're more
like an animal he's sort of making the
connection for the first time in his
Diaries very naive young man still at
the time maybe they are halfway to
animals we now know he was wrong that
actually that you know modern humans
like like everyone else
the for agent Indians were but it's it's
this notion that similarity is the flip
side of difference that I think runs
through a lot of this argument and it's
I mean I I personally think that the
Dennett's solution to this is a good one
which is that animals have a degree of
free will as he puts it the the birds
freedom to fly away is it is a perfectly
decent form of freedom it's better than
the jellyfish's
freedom to float away but it's not as
good as our freedom to sort of think
through the problem and come up with a
solution so there's a gradual addition
of freedom
just as a gradual addition of brain
cells that would probably be my answer
to John Gray but that bird's brain you
know is following physical laws and you
know and the bird didn't create its own
brain and so to fly away is really just
a response of the mechanism of that
brain so it seems to me that in order to
have free will in a radical sense that
you would have to have created your own
brain from scratch so that you could
determine what it is you want yes and I
would argue that that's exactly what you
do every minute of every day you reap
you rebuild your brain from scratch not
entirely but in in in detail as you and
I talking now you're forming a new
memory and so am i of this event we're
forming associations we know that now
how you how we form those associations
because of this tremendously a
significant discovery in my view that
Seymour Benzer and Eric Kandel and
people have made which is that learning
is changes in the expression of genes
that's what learning is it's it's it's
changing the expression of genes which
cause brain cells to change their
connections so in that sense were
fundament you know by deciding what
you're paying attention to you're
changing the state of your brain I mean
I quite agree with you consciousness is
a brain state and somewhere in there is
Francis Crick argues there is something
called the NCC the neural correlates of
consciousness in other words there's
something different about a conscious
pattern of firings in the brain from an
unconscious one and one day we're going
to find out what it is but it I still
think we're just struggling with the
difficulty of getting our heads around a
how something can be both volitional and
mechanical I mean I am you know I'm a
materialist but I also believe in free
will
so a couple of different kinds of
effects upon genes mutations
environmental enzymes could you say
something a little bit about some of the
the new writings on lateral transfer of
DNA yes lateral transfer of DNA is the
question and that is from one species to
another and my my suspicion is that the
lateral transfer of DNA between higher
organisms just doesn't really happen I
think now we've had a good look at a
couple of genomes although were horribly
struck by the similarities you know and
the fact that fruit flies learn using
the same genes that we do we're pretty
sure they got them by common descent ie
that the ancestor of fruit flies on us
was capable of learning and memory the
the the the one exception to that well
there's an exception among the bacteria
I think there is pretty good evidence
that bacteria can literally eat each
other's genes and and stitch them into
their own cells their own their own
chromosomes so in the bacterial world
there is definitely lateral transfer no
no question about that there is some
suggestion that there's a there are some
plants that have hemoglobin in them and
it's thought that they might have got
them from animals by some viral transfer
or something but the big exception in us
the one source of of genes in us that is
not human if you like and it's a very
very big source I mean it's much bigger
than the number of genes we've got is
viral we do know that our genes are
stuffed full of endogenous retroviruses
which are perfectly well integrated
stretches of DNA that spell out the
instructions for making a retrovirus
but they've been kind of tamed and
silenced although there is some evidence
that one or two diseases possibly
including multiple sclerosis might
late these things escaping and
reawakening themselves so in that you
you know were but we're descended from
viruses as well as from people but I
don't think there is any other lateral
transfer of significance I think if
there was we'd have seen it in the human
genome if you remember there was a story
which actually got into the newspapers
early on that that there was a big chunk
of bacterial DNA in our genome it turned
out to be an artifact it was a it was a
dirty petri dish if you like James
Watson and others have proposed that we
should use our knowledge of human
genetics to alter the human genome to
enhance humans and remove to make
diseases what are your thoughts on that
I think it's premature to alter the
germline of humans at the moment I think
it's perfectly acceptable to try gene
therapy to alter human genes in in
organs in the body although I don't
myself think it's gonna work very well
we now know that I think I have no
problem with altering the human genome
gene altering the genome by selection in
other words by bringing several embryos
into the world and deciding which one
you're going to implant based on whether
or not it has say the Huntington's
mutation and I I think Jim is motivated
very largely and very strongly by a
compassion to see people have a chance
to get rid of some of these horrendous
genetic problems but I actually think
that the big opportunity here lies in
applying the knowledge to improve
conventional medical therapies so by
understanding how the Huntington's
mutation leads to Huntington's disease
we can design a drug that will cure it
rather than we can design a genetic
changed to eliminate it so I I actually
think that the the therapeutic impact of
this is going to be fairly conventional
but the knowledge we acquire from the
genome is going to be incredibly
important in that do you think in the
future we may be able to tailor the
appropriate nurture that is needed for
each individual Canberra hang can we
tailor nurture to suit the nature of
individuals I think that's a very good
question and I think the answer is yes
in a sense we sort of already do in the
sense that we well parents do it by
saying my kids good at tennis I'm gonna
go off and give them tennis lessons but
children do it themselves by very
strongly in my experience as a parent
but also my experience as a child doing
more of the things they're good at and
less of the things they're bad at you
know they hate doing things that they've
noticed other people are better at and
if they find they've got a slight talent
in some direction they practice and by
practicing at musical Athletic things or
whatever it is they you know they they
reinforce their nature with their
nurture they the appetite reinforces the
aptitude so I think do i underestimate
social pressure there yes I think so the
uptake of mobile phones with children
the if one child sees another doing well
then that there is social pressure so
nurture is I would not say strong
nurture always ends up with kids doing
what they are good at
yeah no I mean of course this made so
much more complicated picture than I
would accept that and I think the idea
that you would have a genetic test done
on your kids maybe at birth
so that you could say aha he's not gonna
benefit from music lessons in my case
for years or he is in another case then
you know I think that's pretty
far-fetched i I think most I mean after
all you don't really need the genetic
test you kind of find these things out
anyway and I think there gonna be some
pretty bizarre parents if they're gonna
do that kind of thing besides which
we're quite soon gonna swamp ourselves
with too much knowledge here I mean when
we can talk about a few hundred genes
you know it's quite interesting to think
which ones you'd want to change but when
you walk into the physician's office and
he says here's a list of 5,000 genes you
might want to consider changing you know
you're gonna say oh I'll take you know
I'll roll the dice curious if you've had
anything in the works as far as a PBS or
a BBC television special or series based
on anything that you've done yeah the
answer is no c-span is filming me today
which is nice a little bit but no III
haven't made a television series and on
the two or three occasions when I've
made small segments for television I've
found it extremely difficult and a
different skill I think that in a
curious way science doesn't work that
well on television the book is the
natural home of popular science in the
70s and 80s we had people like Kim Jacob
Bronowski doing wonderful series on
science but on the whole television the
span that it likes doing nature and it
likes doing forensic science but it's
not that interested in in in pure
science because it's so lacking in
visual images I mean kind of thing that
I've talked about tonight you know the
promoters on the genes you can do a few
cartoons or something but it's not
really gonna win you
an Emmy yeah sorry given the recent
explosion of knowledge about ourselves
do you think science can or will replace
religion well science replace religion
the answer is no in my view and the
reason is because I personally think I
think I'm gonna put it much too strongly
but that God is in the genes in other
words that that there is a tendency in
us to believe in supernatural
explanations which expresses itself
often in religious terms in in our
societies and then that'll continue
whatever we do some people clearly have
it sort of more strongly than others if
you do twin studies on the heritability
of religion you find zero heritability
for which religion you belong to
obviously and comparatively low
heritability for sort of whether you go
to church but a very high heritability
for extremely sort of fundamentalist
beliefs which suggests that there's
something about certain personalities
that then that they end up being
religions so I don't think extinguishing
religion is any more likely than
extinguishing love so in your genome
book you say that you do not inherit a
high IQ but you can inherit the ability
to develop a high IQ and during your
lecture day you talked about how
although children may have dick dicks
alexia that we should give them the
opportunity to learn to read and I was
wondering if if it does happen to be
true that some children do not have the
ability to taking a higher IQ then is it
possible to overcome that through
nurture
I mean I do I think I think it is
possible to overcome through nurture a
tendency to as it will not be likely to
develop a high IQ because after all you
know what is education it's it's a very
I mean there's one there's one kind of
personality that does well out of the
modern education system we don't really
I think design different education but
to bring out different skills you know
people who are hyperactive people who
are attention span people who are
intuitive rather than analytical or
whatever you know these people aren't so
well catered for in the school
curriculum so in a sense we don't
recognize the diversity of ways of being
intelligent I think that's true to a
degree I think they'll also be you know
innate differences in in skills of
various kinds but yeah I mean I think
the general search for sort of ways of
Education that worked for some kids and
don't work for others is a very
important one I'm not on the whole we're
still fixated on finding the ways of
Education that that works for everybody
rather than trying to differentiate so I
think that would be an interesting
example of adjusting nurture to nature
one more question so the great men with
great fit a lot of what you write about
has some very interesting implications
for our legal system and particularly
the criminal justice system in genome
you mentioned people who are born with a
short gene so they don't produce enough
serotonin so they engage in high-risk
activities to artificially up their
level and you point out that a lot of
people imprisoned convicted of crimes of
violence have a short gene there have
been some interesting recent studies of
the prefrontal cortexes of people
convicted of murderers and they've shown
that the prefrontal cortex of convicted
murders works much differently than
those of normal people and within that
range of convicted murders those
convicted of premeditated murders work
differently from those who are convicted
of crimes of burned by violence
so far our legal system has not tried to
grapple with those issues do you think
they should and if so how I think he
will have to if we'll have to grapple
with those issues I'm not at all sure
how I mean after all you know preventive
justice is a rather horrifying idea and
the idea that you should lock someone up
because they're going to commit a murder
while it made a very good Tom Cruise
film you know it is not necessarily
going to work in in a fair and liberal
society I mean if you wanted to prevent
all murders in the world it's very easy
you lock up people with wide chromosomes
and you've got rid of about 90% of
murders but that's thinned out this room
a bit through for a start
so it's Owen that's in that sense the
things that predispose people to be more
likely to commit murders might turn out
to be quite common like having a white
chromosome like that particular
prefrontal cortex pattern that you're
talking about and you know it might be
that a lot of us are potential murderers
but it's quite clear that you know you
can reduce the actual murder rate by all
sorts of social pressures and legal
legal systems it's often argued that the
kind of thing I'm talking about can lead
people to get off murder charges by
claiming that it was inevitable that
they would commit the murder I've never
thought that was if I was a defense
lawyer I would never really want to
argue the innocence of my clients case
by saying it's inevitable that he was
going to commit murder I mean that
doesn't seem to compute for me so it's
only ever going to be any use in getting
your sentence reduced once you've been
convicted and we're quite used to that
problem already we've got the insanity
defense the you know lots of other
exculpatory arguments I do think that
lawyers the legal profession generally
and judges in particular are aware that
they've got to start grappling with the
biology that's coming their way and I
think a lot of judges saw the OJ Simpson
case and for
gosh I better go do some biology you
know just to see what was what was
heading their way and I'm not quite sure
how it will play out but I don't think
it'll be an earth-shattering overnight
revolution I think there will be little
things that do come in in various forms
into into the legal profession and other
things that don't
Matt Ridley's latest book is nature via
nurture genes experience and what makes
us human it's published by HarperCollins
online at HarperCollins calm